comenzamos con el triángulo abc de este
dibujo y podemos ver que los lados a b y
c son de la misma longitud o que son
congruentes y cuando ambos lados son
congruentes y si este es un triángulo
que tiene dos lados congruentes entonces
tendremos un triángulo
un triángulo
triángulo isósceles
si lees
lo que significa que ese triángulo tiene
dos lados iguales lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es demostrar
a demostrar
demostrar
que los ángulos de aquí en la base
estos ángulos en este caso abc y el
ángulo a se ve estos dos ángulos ángulo
a b c es un ángulo congruente o del
mismo tamaño que el ángulo a c d
en un triángulo isósceles a esos ángulos
les llamamos ángulos base y este ángulo
de aquí arriba lo llamamos ángulo
vértice estos de aquí son los lados o
también llamados piernas del triángulo
isósceles ya este lado que no
necesariamente es igual a estos otros
dos lados se les llama base aquí no hay
mucha información sólo quedamos lados
son iguales pero tenemos bastantes
herramientas acerca de triángulos
congruentes así que tratemos de crear
aquí dos triángulos congruentes y usemos
esto para tratar de demostrar esta
afirmación de que este ángulo es
congruente o igual a este otro ángulo lo
primero es tratar de tener dos
triángulos congruentes una forma de
hacerlo es poner a un punto aquí abajo a
la mitad de la distancia entre b y c más
o menos por acá
este punto le vamos a llamar d por lo
que la distancia del segmento b d es la
misma esta distancia de aquí es la misma
que el segmento de ce es la misma que
está de acá permítanme dibujar el
segmento a de que parte desde este punto
de a hasta el punto de lo útil esto es
que hemos construido dos triángulos y lo
más interesante es que el triángulo a vd
y el triángulo a de c estos dos lados
son congruentes en ambos triángulos y
estos segmentos de aquí estos lados de
aquí abajo también son congruentes entre
ambos triángulos y además comparten este
lado de aquí en medio por lo tanto
sabemos entonces que el triángulo
d
es congruente con el triángulo a de c
y esto lo sabemos por nuestro lado lado
lado si dos triángulos tienen tres lados
congruentes entre sí o iguales pues
ambos triángulos serán congruentes por
lo que ya hemos demostrado nuestra
afirmación porque el ángulo
correspondiente a ahmed es el ángulo
formado por cede en ese otro triángulo
demostrando que el ángulo abc es
congruente con el ángulo acd
ahora tratemos de demostrarlo de otra
manera si tenemos por ejemplo un
triángulo voy a dibujarlo acá si tenemos
un triángulo
con los lados congruentes entonces el
triángulo será un triángulo isósceles
estoy construyendo este otro triángulo
aquí más pequeño
en donde quiero ilustrar esta otra
demostración como que complementaria a
esta primera
aquí tengo mis mi triángulo que tiene
sus lados pero en sus vértices
y comencemos con la idea de que ese
ángulo a veces este ángulo de acá es
congruente con este otro ángulo acb
ok vamos a separar esto para que quede
claro que son dos demostraciones
diferentes aquí yo quiero demostrar que
fue ade
demostrar
el segmento de a hace de hacer es
congruente con el segmento de a a b es
decir que este este lado es igual a este
otro lado o lo que es lo mismo que la
longitud de a hace es igual a la
longitud de a a b esos enunciados son
equivalentes revisemos nuevamente
nuestras herramientas sobre teoremas y
esto nos dice que debemos tener dos
triángulos y esta vez en lugar de
definir un punto intermedio entre b y c
voy a definir de va a ser el punto que
se encuentra exactamente por debajo del
vértice a el punto que se encuentra aquí
abajo exactamente vea este es de de
manera que la línea que va
de esta que estoy indicando aquí esta
línea
es perpendicular a la base oa la línea
que va debe hacer de manera que tenemos
un ángulo de 90 grados como ángulo dv y
también un ángulo de 90 grados en a
veces que es interesante de esto bueno
aquí escribo que se construye
se construye
el segmento ave de tal manera
de tal manera
de tal manera trato de escribir lo más
claro posible que este mismo segmento
ade
sea perpendicular o forme un ángulo de
90 grados con el segmento de c
que nos da esto bueno de este lado vamos
a tener un ángulo otro ángulo y otro
lado que es congruente o que es igual a
en este otro triángulo tenemos este
ángulo que es igual a este otro de acá
tenemos este ángulo que es igual a este
otro de acá y este lado que es común a
ambos por lo que sabemos que estos
triángulos son congruentes por ángulo
ángulo lado por ángulo ángulo lado dos
ángulos y un lado congruentes
una vez que tenemos establecido que
ambos triángulos son congruentes sus
lados y sus ángulos también lo van a ser
así que este lado de acá va a ser igual
a este otro lado de acá demostrando
nuestro objetivo que el lado o el
segmento ac es congruente o igual al
segmento ave si los dos ángulos de la
base son iguales entonces las dos
piernas del triángulo isósceles también
lo van a hacer y si tenemos dos lados
que son iguales o congruentes entonces
los ángulos de la base también lo serán
y en caso de que sientan curiosidad por
este triángulo en particular aquí
dijimos que b era el punto medio entre
beige y acá abajo el punto d es el que
está justo debajo del vértice a pero
aquí abajo podemos demostrar que de ese
punto medio entre b y c
teniendo una demostración adicional ya
que si ambos triángulos son congruentes
entonces este segmento de aquí va a ser
igual a el segmento de acá
va a ser congruente o igual a de s
así pues en un triángulo isósceles el
punto de no solo es el punto intermedio
entre veis también es el que formando el
segmento ade va a ser perpendicular y va
a dividir en dos partes iguales a b y f